هولندا واوكرانيا تتعاني خطه للاطاحه في
روسيا فهل يفعلها ودول اوروبيه تشتكي من
اوكرانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يدفع الثمن
وزوارق الموت الاوكرانيه تتحرش بالسفن
الروسيه مجددا وقوتك افتى يستعد مساحه
كبيره من ايدي الروس الكرم لن يعطي
الاوكران درسا في استراتيجيه الهجوم
المضاد على ارض الواقع وموسكو للاوكرانيين
انتم تهددون والغرب يدفع وبوتين يعود
للطاوله ويضع بين ايدي الغرب عرضا مغريا
فهل يقبلون بالعرض الروسي وبعد اختفاء
وزير خارجيتها عن الانظار في كينت تطلق
حكمها القاصي عليه وكارثه الحريق تاكل
الاخضر واليابس في الجزائر والمغرب يبعث
برساله للجزائريين وسلاح الجو الروسي يعطب
مقاتله امريكيه في سماء سوريا
روسيا الهوب بورقه الموت
هكذا هو حال الحرب ساعه لك وساعه عليك
هجمه ناجحه واخرى فاشله خطه ذكيه وغيرها
خاسره لكن هذه المره لدى شيء اخر نعم
فالرئيس الاوكراني يخطط بسريه تامه وهنا
يفضح ضابط المخابرات الامريكيه السابق
سريه
ليعلن ريتر عن وجود خطه سريه لا تزلنسك
حول بلاده وذلك بقوله ان الرئيس الاوكراني
ونظيره البولندي اندريدودا ربما يتفقان
سرا على انشاء دوله واحده ولذلك يرى الجيش
البولندي ان هذه الخطوه محفوظه بالمخاطر
الى الغايه لانها قد تؤدي الى تصعيد خطير
يصل الى صدام مباشر بين وارسو وموسكو ومع
ذلك فان زيلنسكي قد يقدم عليها بسبب وضعه
اليائس حسب تعبير ريتر وكما تشاهدون ها
نحن لا نتصفح المصدر في وكاله سبوتنك
العالميه ونحن لا نؤكد ولا ننفي ومن الى
معارك البطون الخاويه وبعد ان اعلنت روسيا
ان استئناف سبقه تصدير الحبوب مستحيل بدون
مشاركه موسكو لتهدد خمس دول بفرض قيود على
عبور الحبوب الاوكرانيه نحو اسواق الاتحاد
الاوروبي والى موانئ التصدير فقد اشتكى
مزارع بولندا والمجر وسلوفاكيا ورومانيا
من تنافسيه الحبوب الاوكرانيه رخيصه
الاثمان بسبب وفره انتاجها وهذا الامر دفع
المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى التدخل العاجل حيث
منحت المفوضيه المزارعين المساعدات بقيمه
100 مليون يورو مقابل السماح بعبور شاحنات
حبوب اوكرانيا عبر ترابها وسط مخاوف ان
تغرق حبوب اوكرانيا اسواق الدول المجاوره
وقف طرقات البحر الاسود فيا لك رميكم
الحاتمي يا هؤلاء الم تطلبوا شيئا من
اوكرانيا مقابل اموالكم وفي سياق معارك
الحبوب ايضا قال الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير انه ناقش مع قاده الجيش السبوله
وممر الحبوب في البحر الاسود لمواجهه
الصواريخ والمسيارات الروسيه واضاف
زيلينسكي ان اوكرانيا سترد بقوه على
الارهاب الروسي في البحر الاسود وفق
تعبيره حسنا دعونا ننتظر ردك القوي وهنا
المعارك البحريه تتواصل ولا تنتهي حيث لا
تزال قوتك يا تهاجم الروس فقد اعل
نت وسع الروسيه صاده هجوم
الحربيه الروسيه جنوب غربي البحر الاسود
في المقابل هدد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
باستمرار ضرب جسر القرم رغم انه جسر
المدني لا يستخدم في امدادات القوات
الروسيه وهناك خرجت صاحبه الردود السامه
واللاذعه المتحدثه الروسيه ماريا الساخن
انت تهدد والغرب يدفع لنعد الى حرب
اليابسه حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن تنفيذ لواء البنادق الالي الخامس عشر
عمليته هجوم مضاده ناجحه على محور كرساني
حيث تم تحرير بلده سيركيفكا مشيره الى ان
التقدم الاجمالي للقوات الروسيه بلغ ما
يصل الى 4 كلم على طول الجبهه وما يصل الى
كيلو مترين في عمق تشكيله القتاليه للعدو
فعن اي توغل نتحدث يا ساده الرد الاوكراني
لم يتاخر حيث
كانت كيا قد اعلنت انها استعادت السيطره
على مساحه تقدر ب 16 كلم مربع في الشرق
والجنوب خلال الاسبوع الماضي الارقام
تتحدث والمصادر تتحدث كذلك فاليكم المصدر
16 كيلو مترا مربعا هو حجم الرقعه التي
استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه السيطره عليها
من القبضه الروسيه على جبهات القتال في
الشرق والجنوب وكالعاده نحن لا نصدق نكذب
بل ننقل الاخبار كما هي من الطرفين من
ناحيه اخرى اكد المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان الهجمات بالمسيره على موسكو لن تعطل
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
التي ستحقق كافه اهدافها وتاكيدا لخبر
بيسكو قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
تصدت لهجوم كبير على كييف بطائرات مسجره
روسيه بعد ساعات قليله من تعرض موسكو
لهجوم مشابه اي ان الرد القاسي الذي اعلنت
عنه موسكو لم يتاخر وبين هذا وذاك عادت
روسيا لطاوله الحوار مره اخرى حيث اكد
السكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي
باتروشيه ان موسكو مستعده للحوار حول
تسويه الازمه الاوكرانيه برمتها لكنه قال
انه من الضروري تشجيع الرعاه الغربيين
لنظام على التفاوض
الاحداث والتطورات
بعد ان غاب عن الانظار قبل شهر تقريبا
لاسباب مجهوله وسط تكهنات تتعلق بشؤونه
الشخصيه وخصوماته السياسيه اقالت الصين
وزير الخارجيه الصريح من منصبه واستبدلت
بسالفه
ولكن وسائل الاعلام الرسمي لم توضح اي سبب
لاقاله
اندلعت الليله الماضيه الحرائق في غابات
ولايه بجايه والبويره وجيجل وبومرداس
الجزائر وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الجزائريه
ان الحرائق امتدت الى المناطق الماهوله
بالسكان ما اسفر عن مقتل 34 شخصا واصابه
عشرات الاخرين بجروح واوضحت الوزاره ان من
بين الوفيات 24 شخصا من المدنيين وعشره من
افراد الجيش فيما تم اجلاء اكثر من 1500
مواطن من المناطق المتضرره لكن الوزاره
اعلنت اخماد الحرائق بنسبه 80% من جيجل
وبجايه نشره الى ان الحرائق المستمره تتم
السي عليها كان الله بعون الجزائر
والجزائريين اللهم اجعلها بردا وسلاما على
اهلنا في الجزائر وهنا وبرغم قطع العلاقات
بين البلدين ها هو ملك
المسدس يعز الجزائر في ضحايا الحرائق
وقالت وزاره الشؤون الخارجيه والتعاون
الافريقي بالمغرب ان المملكه المغربيه
تتابع ببالغ الاسى والاسف حرائق الغابات
التي اندلعت في عدد من المناطق بالجمهوريه
الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه واضافت ان
المملكه المغربيه تتقدم بصادق التعازي لما
خلفته هذه الحرائق من خسائر في الارواح
وخالص التمنيات بالشفاء العاجل للمصابين
اعلن الجيش الامريكي تضرر مسيره ضاربه
تابعه له في الاجواء السوريه الاحد الماضي
وتلف محركها جراء اطلاق مقاتله الروسيه
بالونات حراريه باتجاهها
[موسيقى]